first time I ever worked with you do you
remember this it was it was the week
your hot your roof caved in and we had I
mean we we were we knew each other we
weren't quite friends yet and we were
driving from Madison to Milwaukee and
your roof caves in and you're calling
your contact you're calling your wife
and you were Furious and like you I mean
you were you threw at one point I lost
the car I went Ryan Leaf because my
house was literally collapsed washing
down the mountain and nobody that was
home in the house knew what to do yeah
and I'm like go up the [__] ladder
and they're all like well I mean it's
just the water's wet and it's gonna get
on the ladder whoever I order your
milkshake you're still yeah now you're
yelling at the contractor your mid
conversation I hand you the milkshake
and I just like go out and I'm like I
make a phone call or something I come
back you're like I know well no no no no
and then you're like hey dude this
milkshake's fantastic yeah no no
you would not do you remember that at
all do you remember no because it was a
blind rage